this is important you know what is hey
what's up GQ I am a luma and these are
my essentials
[Music]
so my first essential is right here that
is the most important thing with this
chain I have my family with me my sister
my mom my dad and and I and I think that
this is the the most important thing in
my life and this is my essential
everywhere I go this chain represents
the love that I have for my family gonna
wear it yeah yeah now I feel complete
next this is book that I'm reading right
now it's called a little Lancome Vedanta
the white book and this is a very
special book for me very spiritual I
love meditating too and I really love
like reading about life my cheff he gave
it to me
it was really what one day he were on
the plane I was like yo what is that
book about and he put a little message
in it and he he gave it to me I love
them this is a very very beautiful gift
and this is what these boot up he's
about to leave the land KO lanta
everything oh this is powerful over here
I don't say name is old mala when in
Spanish some island is like the rosary
for the Buddhism my aunt she gave it to
me in New York before the Madison Square
Garden so I feel like this is like
protection - yeah I love meditating on
take it with me everywhere everywhere I
go
it has 108 little stones because you're
like the Rosary you know every time you
meditate you say I'm mantra and well
that's a long story but to make you sure
this is a very powerful thing you're not
wearing - okay this is important beer
brush yeah yeah I used to I used to like
crazy I remember the first time I went
to Fashion Week in Paris I didn't I
couldn't go out with this with this
thing you know I became just something
that had to do like every single day I
don't know when I when I let it grow
this is always with me very important
this is another essential and I take it
everywhere but this is like more like a
warm of thing before the before the
shows I always take this with me because
I think like if I don't take care of my
body
nobody's gonna do it for me I feel like
my body is my temple so I have to it
clean and and workout every time I can
do it my iPad this is a real essential
thing because I feel like it's my office
you know I'm building my my own company
my own business I think like it's very
important to have these these kind of
things with you every time every time
you fly just like me when I finish the
show maybe I'm tired but I need to do a
FaceTime with something with someone in
Colombia talking about business or maybe
actually we've talked to talked with my
mom or my dad or yeah I mean my sister I
take care where and I love watching
Netflix like a lollipop well that's
that's that's another another level
I I love this so much the other day
I was in in Europe that was in Barcelona
where my in Barcelona and we saw a
professor who is one of the main
characters of the of the TV show and a
nag like like like a little kid like a
little girl and it was such a big fan of
it you know so so yeah like a sniper but
is one of my favorites absolutely you're
a musician I need to take this with me
everywhere everywhere I go I'm always
making music so for me like this this
headphones are perfect to listen to rob
some references of music that that I do
where everywhere it's impossible not
having these these headphones everywhere
I go well Capanna and is the last the
last time that I did with jboden it's
not because it's mine I really really
like it believe me
capybara is one of my favorites I always
listen to Michael Jackson Justin
Timberlake
of course salsa is my favorite genre and
some reggaeton songs I love reggaeton
one I prefer size a little bit more
a little speaker this just is a little
tiny speaker I take this with me like
literally everywhere everywhere I go
when I'm in at the hotel even before the
shows I use this to to warm up my vocal
cords this this guy's been with me for
awhile and I don't think I'm gonna
change because it sounds great
this is a little collection of watches
that that I have I don't know if you
guys knew but I got Robin in Russia and
he lost everything after that I decided
that I didn't want to to get more
watches and jewelry but I'm a crazy fan
of jewelry and well I have some of some
of the watches my favorite of here Rolex
in a richer richer me I have a AP to be
honest in this industry I know people
that they have 20 25 30 35 40 40
different kind of watches but I really
feel like this is more than enough you
know like I wear because I like watches
I love jewelry what's my favorite watch
of this poor grade question you know you
know what maybe Wow
no I don't gonna I'm not gonna as varies
like it's impossible because because
they're like four different kind of
occasions you know like when a
restaurant is more classy so maybe I use
the AP but maybe I have something more
sporty and I and I use these leather
band Rolex you know this one is like
very classic you know I just
I just got it is one of my favorites so
yeah die I like it - Oh Papa super kiss
the time pace out oh my god this is this
is essential because in not a bag is
easy to lift weights this isn't the one
who carry everything everything I almost
needed this year by my family and my
animals and yeah I'm kind of backs and
this is this is one of the of my
collection my with my closet in Colombia
I had a lot of these these bags and they
are almost all of them there are a
Louisville time I got it in Los Angeles
I've got in Los Angeles I went to the
store and and I was there and there was
a guy he he recognized me and he was
like oh you know what I've been saving
these back for someone for a long time
he was working there in the story and it
was like what kind of bag and I was
looking for this clear one for a long
time and I couldn't find it
give any repairs when we were four
fashion was crazy trying to find it and
I couldn't find and then this guy he
went out with this bag and I was like
bro that's mine
sorry no but there's another guys one I
was like no thank you very much this is
gonna be my friend and I love these back
yeah thanks for having me here thanks
for paying attention of all the
essentials that I have god bless you
guys hope to see you soon my oh my baby
yeah